hi I'm Brooke Watson I'm a data
scientist at the ACLU for those of you
who don't know what the ACLU is it ACLU
stands for the American Civil Liberties
Union and we are an organization that
works to protect and expand civil rights
and civil liberties in America primarily
through advocacy and litigation and so
I'm going to be talking about some ways
that we use our to support our
immigrants rights project in service of
that goal specifically I'm going to be
talking about ten functions that I have
learned about recently or started using
in new ways that I have used in
different projects some of these are
from lesser known packages that I hope
that you will learn about and
incorporate into your own workflows some
of them are from sort of our court ID
vers packages that we all know and love
but hopefully there's a little bit of
something for everybody so I'm going to
be talking about this in the context of
three different immigration cases that
the ACLU has taken in the past few years
Demi's versus Nielson Hernandez V
sessions and mrs. LV ice the packages
that I'm going to be talking about
tabular and DEF read are and vis dat and
ggplot2 and so tab you laser is really
useful for extracting data from raw PDFs
and Daffy helps you look at changes in
data over time so you can look at your
data we've all used read our I suspect
but that compared or when paired with
vis dak can help us look at our data and
then once we have imported all our data
we can use ggplot to look at our data
just really briefly because we have ten
functions so we've got to keep it moving
here are the ones that were going to be
talking about so to start demo movie
Nielsen is a class-action lawsuit the
challenges the arbitrary detention of
asylum seekers so just to start from
scratch the Constitution affords all
people in the United States the right to
due process and equal protection under
the law and that includes immigrants and
that includes asylum seekers so this
means that you can't be detained
indefinitely without a parole hearing
immigration cases tend to take a long
time and so what usually happens is
individuals get parole hearings to
determine whether they
and be released from detention while
they're awaiting their case and so in
early of 2017
we noticed that five field offices five
ice field offices almost entirely
stopped giving parole interviews and
granting parole determinations which
means that people were locked up
indefinitely and so in the middle of the
summer last year the judge ruled that
ice has to give a parole interviews and
determinations to all of those class
members in a timely manner
and they have to report the results of
those determinations to our team so that
we can make sure that they're following
their own policy directive and so the
data question in this challenge is do
the statistics that they're reporting in
their monthly reports actually match the
raw data that they're sending us and can
we take that analysis one step further
and see if there is any evidence that
people are being detained arbitrarily so
we use tabular and daffy to do this in
tabular the real workhorse is this
function extract tables that is sort of
magically pulls tables from PDF and we
can use locate areas interactively to
find out the locations of the columns
that we want to pull out and get in
pages this is really useful if you want
to incorporate the other two into a
function and so locate areas I think
really needs to be done interactively
through some live coding but I am a
coward so we're gonna watch this gif and
so as you can see locate areas you put
read in the name of the PDF and you can
draw boxes around the table or the
column that you want and it'll show you
the coordinates of that table and so we
can we can use that to find the
coordinates these numbers right here
this is sort of a simplified version of
a function that we use to get the number
of pages in a PDF extract all the tables
and sort of find them into a list column
and we can do that every month and we
can use that with across all of the five
different field offices month over
months but sometimes we want to maintain
a healthy skepticism about the data that
we receive from
our opposition in a lawsuit and so
sometimes rerunning an hour markdown the
next month
on new data can provide erroneous
results even if it doesn't run it
doesn't throw any errors and so
sometimes we want to look at the changes
between those two datasets and Daffy is
amazing it's essentially a diff for data
and so what that looks like
again another Coward's demo you create
this object called it that you create
this Daffy object and then you can
render it in HTML and you get a
colorized version of the changes that
are happening between so this is IRS
data and it shows you the rows that are
modified and the rows and columns that
are added or deleted which is extremely
useful so so for example we can run that
pipe from before on a data set save it
to something like an RDS and then run it
on new data and compare the changes and
what we found this is fake data but what
we found was that we had some strange
discrepancies that weren't being caught
by any sort of error handling because in
this example as you can see we have
dates that are sort of in the teens that
are mutated to be ten days earlier and
what was happening was that ones weren't
showing up in the PDF data if they came
right after a back slash because they
got dropped by whatever haunted computer
program that I can only imagine that the
El Paso ICE field office uses but
anyways we were getting these like
really malformed two data sets and just
looking at it and looking at it in this
colorized way it helped us understand
how we could go back to the government
and say what is going on we need to fix
this so the second case is Hernandez V
sessions and this is another case about
whether its constitutional to detain
people for a certain amount of time but
this is about the ability to pay
so again immigration and Asylum cases
can take years and so in the parole
hearing process when judges determined
whether someone can be released from
detention until their ultimate decision
about whether they are granted
in the u.s. they will sometimes be
released RoR and sometimes they will be
required to pay a bond and so what
happens when you are an immigrant or
when you're fleeing asylum from your
home country is that you may not have
thousands of dollars to pay a bond we
had one individual who was detained by
ice agents was granted parole so a judge
said you're free to go you're low-risk
you're going to come back to your
hearings because you have a strong
asylum claim but they they gave him a
$3,000 bond and so he was detained for
four years after a judge said you can go
until we adjudicate your case just
because he couldn't pay that $3,000 and
so when you do this you set up a system
in which people go to jail because they
are poor or they stay in jail because
they are poor and that's
unconstitutional and the judge ruled
that this is a little more than
punishing a person for their poverty so
what we had to do in this case was look
at administrative records so this case
has been adjudicated long before the
ACLU even had an analytics team but this
is still a real problem and there are
still thousands of people who are
detained after they receive bond hearing
or after they receive a bond because
they can't pay it and so we want to use
administrative data from the executive
office of immigration review or E or to
review this and so originally this data
was obtained through FOIA requests but
there's actually a great component to
the or Freedom of Information Act
there's a great provision of the Freedom
of Information Act called the
Beetlejuice provision I don't know if
you're familiar with Beetlejuice but
when you say his name three times he
appears and when you FOIA for the same
data three times in a row and three
separate parties FOIA for the same data
the government is required to put that
somewhere online accessible so that has
happened with your data and so now all
of this immigration court data is
publicly available and hosted on the
departments website but it's really
messy and really hard to work with and
requires not only a lot of data cleaning
knowledge but a lot of nuance and
understanding of the immigration system
and immigration law one component of
working with this really messy data is
that we had tab-separated data saved as
a CSV that when we read in would also
would often jump a line so you would
have one observation that for some
reason just cut off at the end and
skipped and put information in the next
line we'll look at what that looks like
in a little bit and so read ours
I am sure we've all used is useful for
reading and writing many different file
types and Vista is a package that is
really useful in my life to look at data
types and missingness and so here are
some of the functions that we used in
that business is my favorite and read it
file and write file or two functions
that I had never had the misfortune to
need in my workflow I'm typically
reading CSVs tsps and other file types
but it can be really useful to be able
to work with that super raw data so
here's an example of 50 rows of
observations and as you can see there
are some columns where we have a lot of
missingness and then there is one row
where things kind of get thrown off when
a row and a half and this very first
variable is the ID and so that's
something that we really need but we can
tell we can tell there's something going
on here I'll cut to the chase about the
hour and hours of time that we spent
just looking at in a text editor at this
raw information trying to figure out
what was happening for the world's most
boring life coding ever but jump to the
solution which was that we removed
carriage we had a bunch of extra
carriage returns that were just in the
data for no reason this I will say is
not probably a wrecking ball replicable
solution for all of your problems it's
probably not a great idea to always just
remove all of the carriage returns and a
data set but in this case it worked and
so as you can see if we go
back we can see that missingness has
gone away and vis miss is really useful
in the sort of exploratory phase of a
data analysis when you're trying to
understand where the missingness is it
can be useful as a gut check and so
finally I want to talk about some
progress that's being made in the
micelle versus ice case which many of
you may know is the family separation
case so I spoke about this in January at
our studio and this is what we knew this
was a slide I presented in January we
started litigating the case in February
after learning that in November of 2017
an immigrant and her six year old asylum
seeker and her six year old daughter
were separated after being detained at
the border and we I started working on
the project in June and we were still
working on reunifying the children that
had been separated but in in June of
2018 the judge in the case filed an
injunction saying you can't separate any
more children you can't do this anymore
this is at the same time that President
Trump issued an executive order saying
essentially the same thing so family
separations were supposed to have
stopped in June of 2018 and this is the
timeline that we know about now so we
know that separations are occurring
occurring much earlier than November of
2017 and even much earlier than this
case sort of became really talked about
and known in the media it's almost a
year in advance of that ruling right and
so both we both know that these cases
were happening much earlier than we
thought and we know that they've been
happening since the injunction no I will
say the government says that there are
certain exclusions that disallow that
make a separation okay in their mind so
for example if if the parent has a
communicable disease or if they're they
have it's a really serious criminal
record there are
reasons they say that they are allowed
to separate a parent from their children
however we've seen some criminal
exclusions be something as simple as a
parking ticket or as the crew of the
crime of entering the United States so
and I also want to caveat everything I'm
saying with the the fact that the
government has admitted that they don't
know how many families have been
separated and so the data that we're
analyzing in this case are their records
that they're required to report to us
but it's definitely an undercount so the
functions that we're using in this
project or the tool that I'm going to
talk about today are really helpful in
our understanding of how the new
separations are different from the
original ones and what's going on sort
of over time and I'm going to talk about
two functions that I have learned about
recently or that I've started using a
different ways and that I think can be
somewhat misunderstood so a CDF plots if
you are familiar with them are
essentially a compliment to histograms
that show cumulative a distribution of
sort of on a timeline and it's really
useful when our histogram czar really
susceptible to binning effects so we
know that sometimes a histogram can look
a certain way but not actually but but
be kind of a misleading plot and so
that's useful to use those two in tandem
and then kernel density plots are also
sort of a histogram or bar chart
complement and they in this case are
really useful if we're comparing the
proportional makeup of two differently
sized groups and so I'll go back to that
timeline but if we look at it on a nice
EDF this is what it looks like so if
we're looking at the cumulative
distribution or the the sort of running
time line along the bottom of the date
of separation that red line is the date
of the federal injunction and as you can
see it spikes the known separation spike
around last summer and they sort of
continued never really there's never
really a level
after that after last summer and they're
continuing and there's some hints that
it might be on the rise this data is
already old as of yesterday and so
anyways that's the function this is what
those three plots might look like
together and so this can just give you a
sort of a more well-rounded view in this
case the histograms are not so bad they
give us a pretty decent picture no
matter how many bins we use a pretty
decent picture of the pattern but
sometimes this effect is stronger than
others and so this can be a really
useful secondary way of looking at our
data another case in which we can use
two different functions really quickly
to get a quick look at our data is in
looking at the GM
in the graph on the Left we the big
trend that jumps out is that there is so
what we have on the long x-axis is age
and all along the y axis is the number
of people of Chile are separated of each
age and it looks like the children are
sort of more likely to be older there's
not really a lot of kids who are under 5
according to the to the left graph and
you can sort of see the difference
between the red and the blue the red
colors are the old separations that
occurred before June 28th and the blue
are the separations that occurred after
June 28th but when you look at GM
density again when you're just sort of
exploring your data the thing that jumps
out to me is how much of that space
between 0 & 5 is covered by the blue the
new separations and so this is something
that I think is kind of hard to pick up
on in the graph on the left if you're
looking for it you might find it but one
of the things that we're trying to do
with exploratory data analysis is find
things that maybe we weren't looking for
and so the long story short of this and
again we can sort of take the best of
both worlds of those two functions and
look at the distribution of age over
time and compare the new separations to
the old separations
here's some coach that does that the
long story short of this is that under
four percent of the original separations
were of children under five years old
and more than a fifth of the separations
that have happened since June 28 28 that
should today twenty eighteen are under
five and so this is still an extremely
difficult problem that's going on it's
not something that we even know the
scale of but looking at the data that we
do have can help us sort of raise
awareness and raise this issue so I
think the thing I want that I hope you
take away is that looking at data in
different ways can sort of deepen your
understanding of a problem and help you
look for different kinds of solutions or
at least surface issues that you may not
have recognized again here are the tools
that we used today if you have annoying
data that is tab-separated if you have
Naurang data that's stored in PDFs if
you have things that change over time
that you don't really trust or if you
just want to look at plots in different
ways hopefully these are useful so thank
you so much I want to say thank you to
everybody who supports the ACLU and all
of the amazing very very very busy
immigration lawyers that I've been
working with I know there are a lot of
sort of ACLU members in the audience so
thank you
you